what are the goals and ambitions that
you're bringing to this tournament um i
just like to play a few great games um
it's really for the experience playing
against all these great players that
have been here before and um so i can
meet some new people and just try to
play the best chess i can i mean this is
my first time here so i'm just really
hoping to play good games and i'm not
i'm trying not to be that result
oriented i'd say like i just want to
play the best that i can i don't really
want to
set a specific goal because i don't
really want to give myself too much
pressure and just like see where it
takes me as usual i just try to play as
best as i can and be relaxed it's almost
as a vacation because
i just get to be in town and see
you know all of my friends from previous
events and
um yeah just play as best as i can and
hopefully results will come my main goal
well obviously i want to win
i have to say that like i played the
first time i played was like
was for the first year they made the
tournament i'm pretty sure which was um
i don't know i was like 11 or 12. and i
was already like top seed then so the
fact that i haven't won is just like
something that's always been kind of
bothering me because it's like oh it
should happen at some point i feel
really old in this field you can see
like before i felt like it was like kind
of my generation players that were like
come the upcoming and then now we're
like the ones that are leaving now
there's all these young players all
these new 10 year olds it's just really
interesting to see i mean i like to win
i always do but
other than that
my
goals outside of just getting good
results are just
i really want to just chill i just want
to have the most fun that i can i hope
just try my best and see where it goes
and you know try to win the tournament
well it is my first time so i'm kind of
going in with no expectations but i'm
just hoping to take it day by day and
also just play some trust that i'm proud
of i hope to
i'm trying basically i want to be a
fierce competitor play good games and
fight to finish and do my best and
finish at the highest
place possible i'm hoping that i will be
able to improve on my score last year
but on the higher bound i would of
course like to try to win the tournament
although it's very competitive and the
players are very strong so that would be
a hard task but not impossible
[Music]
you